vabbè bene a tutti i ragazzi benvenuti a
questo nuovo video sono farisei oggi
siamo tornati su getting over it con che
voglia ve lo sto dicendo allora è no no
tua madre cremata inter e mi devo
agganciare a questo [ __ ] secchi o se
riuscissi mai a farlo nella vita cosa
veramente impossibile se ci fosse un
modo per riuscire a salire un po più
easy sarebbe gradita non riesco porca
vacca parti per no ho dei problemi con
questo secchio ho dei problemi per
cortesia
no no no no no no non venne gesù salì
quanto tempo per risalire questo pron
avete idea
ok ok va bene sono anche abbastanza
ormai somiglia offrire di farlo niente
sto scherzando perché io parlo andranno
perché ho tirati su ok
no no no perché se devi essere una
persona stupida ok ok mervyn cosa devo
fare qua
basta dai non ma uno scherzo è bello
quando dura povera che non è che posso
andare avanti così tutta la vita ma
canna ok dai ti prego ho quindi io posso
stare in piedi come passata a sinistra
devo andare
presumo comunque a destra anche se si
può fare questa cosa che non sapevo se
provassi a saltare grazie gesù cioè
fammi capire questa montagna non ha
appigli e io come dovrei mai raggiungere
la cima di quest'asta di questo schifo
spiega mi ha proprio non s'ha strisce
non posso dare a sinistra e la destra ma
si assicuri che di qua ha sì perché lì
c'è una porca vacca dna e in sali bill e
non puoi salire su star o no non puoi
non può i ragazzi impossibile però che
non incastri che c'è una tattica che io
non conosco che non credo perché a
questo punto la pre disco barca tra ok
vuoi farmi puoi farmi quasi pensare di
poterci riuscire
porca vacca non crederci devo crederci
dai se solo riuscisse a saltare di quale
qualche parte non so dove
no no no no no tiratissimo non è vero il
mio simbolo canna no dai
no per me sei va bene ero carino ma
niente niente nel mondo è proprio
possibile immaginabile boxes agganciava
le era fatta però a volte lo si
agganciava culo sto gioco di merda
loculo una riduzione mi fanno quelli
nelle speedrun a fare questa cosa che si
aggancia ogni tanto
ogni tanto si aggancia ogni tanto tutti
può adesso no perché fa lui decide come
vuole come li gira la giornata come si
sveglia è quindi svegli maledizioni
svegli bene ti agganciati ti prego ti
prego adottare un bambino sano
andrò a calcutta o qualcosa qualcosa e
no no no no money no no no regna su
supporto schifo so io
oggi su basta basta basta non vogliono
veramente io non ho parole non so io non
ho la cognizione di esistere più la gava
da quanto non ci credeva neanche il
gioco la stava lega io non ho parole io
vi giuro mai nulla è stato così
difficile se adesso cadeau cosa devo
fare questo carrello del della coop
se io adesso cadono no non ti ammazzo
bravo va beh niente provato ragazzo ho
provato il soggetto infatti vinto nome
ragazzi dunque fuori da lì le botte
amiamo se minchiate lo giuro
ve lo giuro sono quasi convinto di
questo cosa ho mai pagato e vagato deve
andare così e vagato cioè nel senso non
deve così sto volte già raga non c'è la
gravità vi giuro cosa sta succedendo e
cosa vedo aiuto ma e non è un non è un
bug cioè deve andare veramente così cosa
sta succedendo mai nella vita
la forza così non è vero mai
ciao amici dove la [ __ ] mammamia raga
mamma mia mamma mia basta basta c'è
veramente io questa mano l'ho distrutta
fuori di ray cooney sulla tastiera oltre
che aveva distrutto due tastiere va bene
sono riuscito veramente questo e finale
quindi c'è proprio finito finito ma non
è che so quanto ci ho giocato in realtà
tanto troppo sono contento di averlo
finito perché non ci metto più umano non
tanto seconda finisce un gioco sei
contento di cia e stato bello è stato
una merda però sono contento di non
doverci mettere più mano basta basta non
ne voglio più sapere
tante scene che taglio ci sono quelli
giro magari botte che voi neanche vedete
grazie a dio
io spero che vi sia piaciuto spero che
la serie miniserie vi sia piaciuta direi
che facciamo anche un best of dei
migliori momenti e lo farò molto presto
quei ragazzi spero sia piaciuto come
attentamente mi piace one to see the
reward giuro solennemente che non sto
registrando strillando questo il che
potrebbe sfoderare la ricompensa per gli
altri scalatori a c'è una ricompensa
ok non stanno registrando sapremo se mi
fa vedere la ricompensa
macché
[Musica]